FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Many apps
work with large sets of data,
but only need to
load and display
a small portion
at any given time.
If you're not careful,
you might request
data you don't actually need,
wasting your user's battery
and bandwidth.
If the data you are displaying
is constantly updating,
it can be difficult to
keep your UI in sync
and still send only a
small amount of information
over the network.
The Paging Library--
part of Jetpack--
tackles these problems,
enabling you to load data
gradually and gracefully.
The library supports both
large but bounded lists,
as well as lists
of unbounded sites,
such as
continuously-updating feeds.
It offers integration
with RecyclerView,
which is typically used
to display large data sets
and plays nicely with
either LiveData or RxJava
for observing new
data in your UI.
The paging library is based
on the idea of sending lists
to the UI with the live data
of a list that is observed
by the RecyclerView adapter.
It then builds up on this
idea by adding paging
so you can load
content gradually.
Let's go over the main
components of the library,
and see how they fit in
your app's architecture.
The core elements in
the Paging Library
are the PagedList
and the DataSource.
A PagedList is a collection
that loads data in chunks,
known as pages, asynchronously.
A DataSource is the base class
for loading snapshots of data
into a give page list.
Data sources can be backed by
the network, database, file,
or anywhere you want
to retrieve data from.
You create the DataSource using
a DataSource.Factory object.
The Paging Library also
provides a PagedListAdapter
which helps you present
data from PagedList
in a RecyclerView.
The PagedListAdapter is
notified when pages are loaded,
and it uses DiffUtil to
compute fine grain updates
as new data is received.
The Paging Library provides
the LivePagedListBuilder class
for getting a LiveData
object of type PagedList.
To create a
LivePagedListBuilder,
pass in the dataSourceFactory
object and a paging
configuration.
If you prefer working with
RxJava instead of LiveData,
then just use the
RxPagedListBuilder.
It's constructed similarly
to LivePagedListBuilder,
but instead of a
live data object,
it will return an
observable or flowable
depending on what you need.
Let's take a look at some
common scenarios of loading data
from a database or a
retrofit-based network source,
and see how the
Paging Library helps.
So, first case, let's
say that the database
is your DataSource.
The Room Persistence library
provides native support
for Paging Library data sources.
For a given query,
Room allows you
to return a DataSource.Factory
from the Dao,
and handles the implementation
of the DataSource for you.
Second case.
Let's say that the
database is a cache
for data loaded from network.
So here you would still
return a DataSource.Factory
from the Dao, but
you will also need
to implement another paging
component, a boundary callback.
The boundary callback
loads more data
when the user gets near
the end of the data that's
in the local cache.
After the data is inserted, the
paging library automatically
updates the UI.
But don't forget to associate
the boundary callback
with the live PagedListBuilder
you created earlier.
That way it can be
used by the PagedList.
Third case.
Having only the network
as your DataSource.
Here you will have to
create both your DataSource
and your DataSource.Factory.
But when choosing which
data source type to extend,
consider what your
backend API looks like.
If you need to request data from
your backend based on a key,
you will extend from
ItemKeyedDataSource.
Let's take an example.
You might need to
get the first 100
comments added to
a GitHub repository
after a certain date.
Then the date will be the
key for your DataSource.
ItemKeyedDataSource
allows you to define
how to load the
initial page, as well
as how to load items both
after and before a keyed entry.
If your backend exposes
APIs that work with pages,
then you would extend
from PageKeyedDataSource.
For example the search
repositories GitHub API
returns paginated items.
In the GitHub API
request, you need
to specify the query,
which page you want,
and optionally, the
number of items per page.
And dependent on how you create
your network data source,
you will need to implement a
DataSource.Factory that knows
how to create your data source.
For full examples of how to
implement all of these cases,
including how to handle error
cases or retry mechanisms,
check out our samples on GitHub.
OK, let's sum it up.
Here's what you'll need
to do to integrate paging.
You'll need to define
your DataSource,
create a boundary
callback if it's needed,
create a LiveData of a
PagedList with the help
of a LivePagedListBuilder,
update your adapter
to be a PagedListAdapter,
and then finally observe
the LiveData a
PagedList in your UI,
and send the PagedList
to your adapter.
That's it.
Just five steps.
Check out our documentation,
code samples, and collab,
and start using
the Paging Library
to provide smooth-performing
lists for your users.